Not all Android users interact with
their devices in the same way.
And that is why it is important to make
sure your app is usable by anyone.
This includes users who have visual,
physical or age related limitations
that prevent them from fully seeing or
using a touch screen.
And users with hearing loss who
may not be able to perceive
audible information and alerts.
To make these considerations easy for
developers, Android provides
accessibility features that help
users navigate their devices more
easily including text-to-speech,
haptic feedback, gesture navigation,
trackball and directional navigation.
Even better, our experts have created a
nifty checklist to help developers know
what to focus on when making
their apps accessible.
So, let's take a look.